accusé de violences un député ex macro
nist devient membre d'une commission en
lutte contre les violences
majid el guerrab s'était illustré en
2017 pour des violences à coups de
casque de scooter contre son collègue
socialiste boris fort il vient malgré
tout d'intégrer la commission d' enquête
sur la lutte contre les groupuscules
d'extrême droite en france une décision
dénoncée par plusieurs politiques
maurice faure lui attend toujours que
justice soit faite dans cette affaire
l'écoutent cette balafre que je porte
désormais sur le crâne pour la vie ben
c'est le rappel en fait de mon coma se
le rappelle que c'est pas passé loin
pour moi le temps judiciaire est long et
quand on est une victime comme moi et
qu'on est en attente de jugement
trois ans est particulièrement long
pendant ce temps mon agresseur continue
de siéger à l'assemblée il a changé
récemment deux groupes parlementaires il
est invité dans les médias vous voyez en
regardant cette cicatrice qui est là
pour la vie que que j'ai sur le crâne
mais bien je me rappelle tout ça et ça
me donne du coeur en fête pour continuer
le combat pour la justice avec mes
avocats pour aussi continuer le combat
qu un combat contre la violence en
politique